حسنًا ، سيتعين عليها القدوم معنا
الآن ، حسنًا ، يجب أن تذهب معهم
طفلة وقفت
هذا هو اعتقال كايا رول البالغة من العمر ست سنوات التي تم التقاطها
بكاميرا الجسد ، تم القبض على كايا
وربطها بسحّاب من قبل ضابط موارد المدرسة
في وجهها  المدرسة الابتدائية في
أورلاندو فلوريدا في عام 2019
[موسيقى
] قالت المدرسة إن كايا بدأت تضرب
مساعد مدير المدرسة
وتصرخ بعد أن قيل لها إنها
لا تستطيع ارتداء نظارتها الشمسية في
الفصل الدراسي تقول عائلتها إن كايا كانت
تعاني من آثار جانبية لانقطاع التنفس أثناء
النوم  التشخيص الذي شاركوه مع
المدرسة ، لكن انتهى الأمر بنقل طالب الصف الأول
إلى مكتب المدير
واتُهم لاحقًا بارتكاب
جنحة جريمة جنائية
[موسيقى]
الاعتقال في فلوريدا ليس لديه قوانين الحد الأدنى للسن
مما يترك الأطفال من جميع الأعمار
مؤهلين للاعتقال  من قبل ضباط إنفاذ القانون
في مدرسة
كايا عندما تم القبض على طفلة تبلغ من العمر ست سنوات
تم تقييد يديها خلف ظهرها
والسبب الوحيد لتقييد
يديها بالأصفاد هو أن  قال فايسر
إنه لم يكن لديه أصفاد صغيرة
بما يكفي لتناسب معصمها ،
كان كايل قصيرًا جدًا لدرجة أنه اضطر للذهاب والعثور
على مسند قدميها لتقف عليه
بحيث تكون في
مستوى الارتفاع المناسب له ليأخذ لقطة لها.
لقد كنت خائفًا ومربكًا حقًا ، كنت
مثل ما سبب
وجود ضباط الشرطة هؤلاء بالنسبة لي ،
فقد تضاعف عدد أجهزة إنفاذ القانون المبلغ عنها
في مدارس فلوريدا تقريبًا في
العام السابق لاعتقال كايا ،
والآن تريد أن تلمسه ، لن أؤذي
ما يجب علينا ألا نفعله  وضع الأصفاد على
أطفال في السادسة من العمر ، لا تعرف تقريبًا أي
موقف يكون فيه هذا
استجابة مناسبة ، يقول الخبراء إن ارتفاع
أعداد الاعتقالات المدرسية في الولاية
يمكن أن يُعزى بشكل كبير إلى
تشريع تم تمريره في
أعقاب إطلاق النار على مدرسة بارك لاند
يتطلب قانون مارجوري ستونمان دوجلاس
للسلامة العامة في المدرسة الثانوية
أن يكون لدى جميع
المدارس العامة في الولاية التي يجب أن
تشمل كلاً من المدارس التقليدية والمدارس المستقلة
فردًا مسلحًا في
كامبو  في جميع الأوقات ، يمكن أن يكون
ضابط إنفاذ قانون محلفًا يتم تنفيذه باعتباره
ضابط موارد مدرسية ، ويمكن أن يكون
حارس أمن خاصًا مسلحًا أيضًا
ولكنه ليس ضابط إنفاذ قانون محلفًا
وليس لديه سلطات اعتقال
أو يمكن تنفيذه من خلال ما
نحن نسمي برنامج الوصي في فلوريدا ،
وهو عبارة عن جيش وموظف في
المدرسة ، لذا فإن ضباط الموارد المدرسية هم في بعض
النواحي جزءًا من اتجاه أكبر نحو
تشديد الهدف ومحاولة
حماية المدارس ،
سقطت الاعتقالات المدرسية في فلوريدا على مستوى الولاية
خلال العام الأول للوباء
ولكن الآن  يتجه الفلوريون إلى
الفصول الدراسية الشخصية وفقًا لـ
ACLO في 2018 كان عدد ضباط الشرطة أكثر من الممرضات في الفصول الدراسية في فلوريدا
وأكثر
من ضعف عدد ضباط الشرطة
مقارنة بالأخصائيين الاجتماعيين أو
علماء النفس في المدرسة
. تريد أسرة القاهرة أن
يفهم الجمهور أن صدمة الاعتقالات
ترك ندوبًا عقلية دائمة على الأطفال
الذين لا يزال كايا يعيش معهم بعد
ذلك بعامين
قبل
وقوع حادثة كايل  سيدة شابة رائعة
وردية ، نعم ، هل ترى أي
شخص هناك
أرادت أن تعانق الجميع أرادت
أن تغني لكل شخص أرادت أن
ترقص لكل شخص كان
رائعًا نتيجة
للحادث ، تم تشخيص تايا باضطراب ما بعد الصدمة
بقلق شديد من الانفصال كانت
تقريبًا  لديها أسلوب حياة منعزل الآن
أصبحت طفلة مختلفة تمامًا
[موسيقى
] أشعر بالحزن لما حدث في المدرسة
مع ضابط الشرطة
لأنني أعتقد أنه
كان يعني حقًا بالنسبة لي
[موسيقى] وهو
يقدم الألعاب في
مذكراتي التي أصدرتها قضية كايا في الأخبار الوطنية
بعد  قام قسم شرطة أورلاندو بالتحقيق في طرد
ضابط الموارد المدرسية الذي اعتقلها قائلاً
إن اعتقال أي شخص دون
سن 12 عامًا يتطلب
موافقة وأنه لم يتم الحصول على هذه الموافقة في حالة كايا ،
تقول الأسرة إن تهمها قد تم إسقاطها في
الخارج
، لا بأس بذلك ،
لا  ثم عملت العائلة المالكة مع
عضو مجلس الشيوخ عن الولاية لرفع الحد الأدنى للسن
التي يمكن فيها اعتقال الطفل في فلوريدا.
دخلت حيز التنفيذ في 1 يوليو
2021 ، فهي تنص على أن أي طفل في فلوريدا
دون سن السابعة لن يتم
القبض عليه أو الحكم عليه إلا
في حالات الجناية القسرية
[تصفيق]
لقد استغرقت الكثير من
القتال وأنا قاتلت بشدة لأنني  لم
أكن أرغب في رؤية هذا يحدث لعائلة
أخرى لا توقف معركتنا ، فقد بلغت
الثامنة من عمرها وكان هذا في مايو
وقالت لي إنها تقول الجدة وهذا يعني أن
قانون بلدي لم يعد يحميني ،
والعائلة المالكة تريد الحد الأدنى للسن
الاعتقال في فلوريدا مرة أخرى
ويريدون أيضًا أن تنظر الدولة
في دور منظمة إنقاذ الطفولة ككل ،
ما نحتاج إلى القيام به هو إجراء
محادثات جادة حول ما إذا كان يجب أن
يكونوا حاضرين في المدارس على الإطلاق ، ثم
نحتاج إلى ربط ذلك مع  إلقاء نظرة صارمة
على الطريقة التي ندربهم بها على
الطرق التي نحاول بها تقليل
تحيزهم عندما يتعلق الأمر بالتعامل مع
الطلاب الملونين للتأكد من أنهم إذا
كانوا سيحضرون ، فإننا نقوم بتقليل
النتائج السلبية غير المقصودة
حسنًا بالنسبة لكايا ، المستقبل طريق طويل
يمكنك تعلم التعايش معه ،
ويمكنك تعلم استعادة مظهر
الحياة الطبيعية ولكن لا يوجد شيء مثل
علاج ptsd
[الموسيقى]
لك